Salut les petits mentalos !
Oui je vous appelle "les petits mentalos", au lieu de "la team mentalo"
aujourd'hui je fais ce que je veux !
On est en plein été, et on fait ce qu'on veut l'été !
Aujourd'hui je vais vous donner 5 astuces pour bien négocier.
Ca fait quelque temps que dans les commentaires vous me demandez de faire une vidéo sur ce sujet là.
On est mercredi, c'est le jour des astuces, ça tombe bien.
Mais il y a quand même des nuances entre négocier son salaire, négocier un prix dans un magasin, négocier avec quelqu'un...
Donc au lieu de traiter les sujets un par un dans un Master Class, je me suis dit que j'allais faire plutôt les 5 astuces fondamentales pour une bonne négociation.
C'est applicable à toutes les négociations, quelles qu'elles soient,
de l'argent de poche, jusqu'à se faire embaucher quelque part ou à renégocier son salaire, par exemple.
Egalement pour obtenir un prix dans un magasin...
Ce sera à vous après d'adapter ces conseils suivant la situation dans laquelle vous êtes.
Et je vous le dis, une négociation commence quand la personne vous dit "non".
Première astuce: Une négociation, ça se prépare en avance.
Alors très en avant, ou quelques minutes avant peu importe.
Ca c'est suivant l'ampleur de la négociation, du projet et du but.
Mais vous devez vous préparer mentalement, préparer votre argumentaire.
Préparez, anticipez un peu les phrases d'opposition que vous allez entendre, pour ça  il vous suffit de vous mettre à la place de la personne qui va être en face
et de réfléchir à ce que vous diriez à sa place pour vous contrer, comme ça vous vous préparez déjà la contre argumentation.
Deuxième astuce: Savoir qui est en face.
Alors si c'est votre patron, vous savez qui est votre patron.
Si c'est pour un entretien d'embauche, faites des petites recherches avant.
Quelle est sa place dans l'entreprise ? Depuis combien de temps il est là ? Est-ce qu'il a un pouvoir de décision fort ou pas ? Est-ce qu'il va devoir vous revendre lui encore une fois à quelqu'un d'autre ?
Si vous êtes dans un magasin, essayez de voir qui est le vendeur ou la vendeuse, de le regarder, de l'observer un petit peu.
De comprendre ce rapport avec les autres vendeurs, est-ce que c'est une personne qui est un peu chef ?
Est-ce que c'est un stagiaire ? Dans ces cas là, le stagiaire ne pourra pas négocier avec vous.
Troisième astuce: Préparer des solutions alternatives.
Il existe potentiellement des solutions alternatives qui peuvent vous convenir dans votre négociation.
Anticipez les à l'avance. Ça vous permettra de les sortir comme des jokers,
au moment où la personne dirait: "Ecoutez, ça aurait été pour autre chose, j'dis pas..."
Là il faut avoir la réponse.
Donc préparez des solutions alternatives des choses qui peut vous convenir mais préparez les à l'avance pour être toujours très déterminé dans votre négociation après.
Quatrième astuce: le marchandage et les concessions.
Très important les concessions !
Pourquoi ? Parce qu'une négociation, contrairement à ce qu'on pense, c'est fait pour que les deux parties soient contentes de ce qui vient de se passer.
Il n'y en a pas un qui vient prendre le pouvoir sur l'autre, ce n'est pas réellement ça une négociation.
On le pense souvent, mais dans le sens final, et tous les négociateurs vous le diront quel qu'il soit, même s'il y a une notion de pouvoir,
on veut que les deux parties soient contentes.
Donc tout du long, les deux parties vont faire des concessions, pour à un moment donné, se trouver en face à face.
Régler un petit peu le curseur.
C'est pour ça d'ailleurs, qu'on voit souvent des négociations, où il y en a un qui parle là,
l'autre ici.
Et puis la personne baisse un peu.
Et l'autre fait un effort.
Et à un moment donné, ils se retrouvent.
Ca c'est l'exemple de base, mais il faut le généraliser et penser que quoi qu'il arrive, il va falloir marchander et faire des concessions soi même.
Donc effectivement, il vaudrait mieux peut-être mettre la barre un peu plus haute au départ,
pour pouvoir la redescendre plus facilement.
Je vous l'ai dit au début de la vidéo, une négociation commence quand la personne dit "non".
Et bien plus généralement, quand la personne est trop ferme, c'est-à-dire met des ultimatums, des choses qui ne sont plus possible,
ne vous laissez pas intimidé par ça.
Vous n'avez rien entendu, ou en tout cas ne réagissez pas à ça.
C'est bien souvent d'ailleurs qu'une question d'égo, donc après on a envie derrière de mettre encore plus d'égo,
c'est pas comme ça que la négoiation va aboutir,
donc ne faites pas attention aux ultimatums que la personne vous mets, par contre
si vous vous en mettez un, même si ce n'est pas un gros,
ça peut-être par exemple à un moment donné vous n'êtes pas d'accord sur un prix avec le vendeur dans un magasin et vous dites:
"Ecoutez c'est comme ça, ce n'est pas très grave, tant pis. Je m'en vais, je vais en acheter un ailleurs."
Partez vraiment. Partez jusqu'à temps qu'il vous rattrape.
Et si il ne vous rattrape pas, partez quand même.
Parce que c'est ça le secret d'une bonne négociation, c'est d'être prêt à renoncer.
Si vous avez un objectif, un but, avec un argumentaire, vous savez jusqu'où vous êtes prêts à descendre,
puisque vous vous êtes préparé à l'avance.
C'est pourquoi il y a beaucoup de négociations qui sont un petit peu éventées, par exemple pour l'achat d'un objet.
Si quelqu'un va acheter un objet, il essaye de le négocier mais de toute manière quoi qu'il arrive il le veut.
Et même au prix fort. C'est pas très grave. Donc il joue à essayer de négocier.
Et ça le vendeur en face le sait, le perçoit. Et il ne va donc faire aucun effort.
Parce qu'il sait que la personne n'est pas prête à renoncer.
Si vous êtes prêt à renoncer si la négociation n'aboutit pas, alors vous ne serez que plus fort.
Merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette vidéo, j'espère que ça vous aura plu.
J'espère aussi que ça vous servira un petit peu cet été.
Et...pendant que vous êtes là...
on peut, peut-être s'arranger pour...
pour un petit...
POUCE EN L'AIR !
Si vous avez d'autres conseils à donner pour la négociation, n'hésitez pas à nous les mettre dans les commentaires.
De toute manière je les lis tous avec grand plaisir.
Et ça me ferais très plaisir, de vous voir aussi échanger vos propres astuces.
Pensez à regarder la vidéo de demain, elle est très importante.
N'hésitez pas à faire tourner cette vidéo et à vous abonner à la chaine avant de partir puisque le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an
depuis le premier janvier.
Alors rendez-vous demain à 17H.
Ciao !